55 57 prozent der 25 bis 34
ich habe jetzt schon alles vergessen
andere frage hallo mein name ist khan
herzlich willkommen wir heute zu einem
neuen video von wir haben uns in der
buchhandlung ein unnützes wissen wieso
unnütz ist wissen wollen ganz klar das
passt das einfach farblich zu meinem
t-shirt
wir sind befinden sich ganz ganz viele
verschiedene karten auf denen immer
verschiedenes unnützes wissen draufsteht
wie beispielsweise hier steht jetzt alle
neun tage alle neun stunden oder alle
neun minuten wird in deutschland ein
patent angemeldet
und dann muss man sagen ob alle neun
tage neun stunden oder alle neun minuten
auf der rückseite steht dementsprechend
immer die lösung
deswegen habe ich mir eine high na na
danke der nachfrage jetzt auch kultische
laut und deutlich rede news.de
der herrgott julis auf jeden fall immer
eine unnützes wissen sache vor und ich
muss dann sagen was ich für richtig
halte dann mache ich die augen zu und
erzählt dann runter 321 und sagen
entweder richtig oder sie klatscht mir
eine wenn es falsch war
die innere uhr des menschen ist enorm
abhängig von umwelteinflüssen wie der
aktuellen wetterlage zweite etwas das
viele scheiße
zweitens stellt sich bei der
zeitumstellung von sommer auf winterzeit
nach einer woche automatisch irgendwann
drittens folgt einem 25 stunden rhythmus
was ich würde sagen dass die innere uhr
des menschen sich nach einer woche
automatisch von winter auf sommerzeit
umgestellt
okay dass ich sagen nein wieso hat denn
die menschliche rund 520 stunden
rhythmus
statistisch gesehen liegt der mensch
alle erstens 4,8 minuten 238 3 minuten
oder drittens 121 5 minuten
du liegst auf jeden fall alle drei
sekunden
ich sag das in der mitte also b glaube
ich
21 dann geht das hat mich zu bewegen
was war dann richtig dass erst alles
hier kommen acht minuten hast du
meintest das in der mitte 38 mal drei
minuten weil ich dachte 4,8 minuten
alter manche menschen hat man einfach
auf die fresse so da kann man ja nicht
alle fünf minuten lügen 20 prozent 40
prozent oder zehn prozent der kinder in
deutschland unter acht jahren kann nicht
schwimmen 20 prozent unter acht jahren
gar nicht schwimmen oder b 40 prozent
oder 18 kann ich schwimmen oder zehn
prozent unter 8 jahren können nicht
schwimmen also acht jahre ist relativ
jung
du bist ja gerade sieben geworden von
daher bisher bald erste allerdings
glaube ich dass zehn prozent zu wenig
ist also auf jeden fall wieder unter 20
oder unter 40 prozent weil ich bereue
ich acht jahre alter kann ich mit acht
jahren schon schwimmen eine ewigkeit
später die scheiße ist ich merke schon
wieder meiner wange drei wochen später
kannst du schwimmen ja erst 27 oder 40
prozent acht jahren können ich will
meine fresse es ist also schwierig hier
heutzutage ich sage oder darunter 20 die
sirene - das rappelt in der kiste ene
mene meck und du bist weg ich sah 40
können unter herunter
der lebensweise war strauß solter neues
mehr als zwei millionen chinesen leben
in höhlen für zweitens mehr als zehn
millionen chinesen leben in höhlen oder
drittens mehr als 30 millionen chinesen
30 millionen die sache ist wenn man
jetzt mal ganz blöd nachdenkt über zwei
millionen ist eigentlich immer richtig
weil auch über 10 millionen über zwei
millionen
danke danke ich schwanke gerade so ein
bisschen zwischen über zwei millionen
über 10 millionen ja ich allerdings vor
hin dass in der mitte genommen habe also
dies mit dem schwimmen 20 prozent würde
ich jetzt sagen über zwei millionen dem
grinsen nach süden liege ich wieder
verheilt
was wusste wirklich nicht so falsch
bulgarien lieben erstens 55 7 prozent
der 25 bis 34 jährigen aber ich habe
jetzt schon alles vergessen andere frage
in den usa haben arbeitnehmer
durchschnittlich ersten vier urlaubstage
zur verfügung 214 urlaubstage zur
verfügung und drittens 40 urlaubstage
zur verfügung
ich glaube das weiß ich definitiv nicht
vier urlaubstage wir haben ak 14 oder 40
ich weiß nicht in spanien wenns locker
40 oder griechenland oder so aber in
amerika habe ich echt überhaupt kein
plan 14 urlaubstage sind auf jeden fall
auf 14 oder 40 40 ist hart viel ist wie
gesagt ich 14
was würdest du sagen ich weiß die
antwort danke
3 schade ein doppel knoten der sich
ständig lockert wird auch erstens
mädchen knoten genannt zweitens
gordischer knoten genannt oder drittens
altweiber knoten genannt ein doppeltop
dass ich ständig lockert ja deshalb nun
ich schwanke so ein bisschen zwischen
gordischer knoten oder mädchen knoten
mädchen knoten ist allerdings ein wenig
frauenfeindlich amagá war auch franka
knoten machen deswegen sage ich
gordischer knoten und du kannst jetzt
runter und gibt eine backpfeife
in deutschland gibt es erste 1600 erms
schulen bald mit 4600 tanzschulen oder
drittens 8600
diese tanzen denn so viele menschen
belgrad ein bisschen weil in bielefeld
gibt auf jeden fall locker 20 30
tanzschulen oder irgendwie so und wenn
ich überlege bielefeld ist ja noch
verhältnismäßig echt eine kleine
großstadt ich sage dass es in ganz
deutschland 4600 an schulen gibt fliegen
erstens weiß und gelb sind die mit
abstand am häufigsten verwendeten farben
weiß und wenn man geld weiß und gelb
sind die mit abstand am häufigsten
verwendeten farben auf nationalflaggen
zweitens weiß und blau sind die abstand
am häufigsten verwendeten farben auf
nationale fragen oder drittens weiß und
rot sind die mit abstand am häufigsten
verwendeten farben nationalflaggen
also weiß auf jeden fall entweder gelb
blau oder rot wenn ich erst mal
überlegen würde ich eigentlich sagen
glaube selber auf kleinsten gelblich rot
oder blau
das ist echt 50 50 würde ich sagen ich
bin voll vielen klagen ist einfach und
gerechnet zwei möglichkeiten 50 50
dieser nämlich dass mit ihr auf
das ist genauso ein fifty fifty gegen
die mit den tanzschulen wo ich komplett
daneben lag
ich sage meine damen und herren es gibt
auch den nationalflaggen immer was heißt
immer also den meisten fällt weiß und
rot oder blau sage ich jetzt in dem
innere ist das kabel in der kiste ihnen
mini mac und du bist weg fast schon
wieder suchen
massa 4 verschlechtert
das ist jetzt die letzte frage ich hatte
bisher glaube ich irgendwie eine oder
zwei fragen so richtig klar zu sehen der
welt ist der maschsee in japan die sicht
reicht bis 115 meter tiefe 242 meter
tiefe oder drittens 108 meter tiefe
wow super frage danke habe ich mir
selbst ausgedacht ach es ist 15 meter
schon hat viel überlege ich bin 20 meter
groß da kann ich nicht widerstehen
irgendwann später ich sage das sind
damit ja ja was war das noch mal
42 ja ja ja ja das ist ja kreis oder
dritte mal was richtig ja wie ich lade
ich falsch hier so viele
das war es jetzt vom wieder meine damen
und herren ich habe einfach einige ohne
zu wissen sachen beantwortete er nicht
beantworten das falsch beantwortet wenn
euch das video hier gefallen hat das
gerne mal einen like da wenn ihr das
ganze noch mal sehen wollte und jetzt
meine damen und herren ja kommt das auto
aber wenn ihr bock habt könnt ihr auch
mal meinen job ab checken oder mein buch
kaufen wartet man ganz kurz weil das
nicht so dass wir vorne noch
wunderschönes weihnachtsgeschenk passt
farblich perfekt zu meinem t-shirt
hier können jetzt jemanden kanal
abonnieren oder hier unten meinen
schenken ihr findet ihr zwei andere
videos und wenn ihr schon abonnent seid
könnt ihr auf die glocke klicken dann
willkommen die benachrichtigungen